this map is interesting because it is
the heaviest element that is not
radioactive and it is used but
particularly in an alloy which called
woods metal which is a very low melting
alloy will even melt in boiling water
and there were endless practical jokes
where you could buy woods metal spoons
and you give it somebody to stir their
tea and it melted in their tea and they
look surprised so here is a very old
sample of bismuth this is a bismuth rod
and you can see it's packed up really
quite nicely but we can open this and we
can go in and have a look to see what it
is you know so here if we pull it out
carefully see bismuth yeah really old
sample from Johnson Matthey now let's
see if we can find out what the purity
is so it's a 99.9 percent really quite
nice sample of bismuth rod bismuth
surprisingly is not very poisonous
compared to the fact that laid is very
poisonous and so there are some
suggestions that we should be exploring
more the chemistry of bismuth as a
catalyst because if it works well then
it could be used in chemical processes
with much less danger than some of these
other materials so if we can push it out
from this old paper packaging and you
can see it's packaged really quite
nicely here you can see the bismuth mill
itself bismuth is used is in catalysis
just to attenuate selective reactions so
perhaps we might use bismuth with a
platinum group metals like palladium or
platinum even to make chemistry go a
little bit more selectively it's really
beautiful element really nice we'll pop
that back in there nice to see
radioactivity can be imagined and this
was Lisa might note the thought of this
model the very early stages of
radioactivity you can imagine the
nucleus the center of the atom rather
like a blob of water and if you imagine
a drop of water as it gets bigger and
bigger it becomes unstable and will
easily split into two
it just happens that bismuth is the
larger size that's not retroactive